[Music]
hey guys it's justine and i'm here at
google i o and i had so much fun
watching the presentation and now i'm
gonna head over and chat with sundar the
ceo of google he just left the stage so
let's go have a chat
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you so much for sitting down and
i'm just so excited this is actually my
first i o oh all welcome and you you
timed it well we're back in person in
shoreline did you enjoy it i did did you
enjoy it yeah of course i loved you know
it took me a while to get used to having
audience back and the reactions back and
so i i had to go through an adjustment i
think but i love being here like in the
auditorium too it was just like feeling
that energy i feel like everyone missed
that and i i hope it continues i think
it's time for people to come back and
get on with our lives i felt like
watching the presentation it really felt
like google was trying to be additive to
technology and not something that's like
distracting in your life so how do you
feel that that kind of carries through
towards google's mission no it is you
know if you if you go back to search
search was always about trying to get
you the answer as quickly as possible
and and not
the focus was that and so in some ways i
think a lot of what you saw today
is people are living their lives doing
what they are trying to do
we want to
find those moments where if they need
help be helpful as quickly and
efficiently as possible so yeah that
affects how we think about it and it's
incredible with your whole career at
google too and you've been there for so
long so what's it been like to really
see the entire tech industry just change
like right before your eyes and even
having like a huge part in that wow i
mean it is i mean
who would have thought the internet
would reach where it is today and uh you
know i couldn't have quite foreseen it
but you know early on i realized that
finally you have a medium which is going
to you know pretty much touch everyone
in the world eventually and so it's been
thrilling to be part of that ride and
being at google gives you a chance to do
that at scale and impact a lot of people
so
but i think look the the great thing
about technology is
for for people who are young and coming
into it
the next decade the next two decades are
going to have as much evolution in as
many new things as what we you know i've
seen in my
last two decades so i think that's
that's the great thing about technology
is there any key moment that you're like
that was the most meaningful thing that
you felt that had like a huge impact
towards the end when it all comes
together you know when we're investing
in ai and trying to help people as we're
testing the prototype and giving it to
people who could be you know either deaf
or hard of hearing or didn't understand
a language you know that's where you see
how it can all come together and touch
people's lives and so i think that's the
potential of technology the kind of
thing which makes me get up in the
morning and uh coming to work so that's
what i would say yeah and i feel like
now even just with the internet and
being able to touch that many lives is
so incredible and i think accessibility
is so important i mean how do you guys
kind of go through that whole process of
deciding what is something that you need
to include for accessibility and kind of
just carry that through you know
we've deeply cared about it in our
mission and so you know if anything
we're constantly across every products
be getting to everyone in the world uh
trying to make it as affordable as
possible making sure we are thinking
through deeply for people with
disabilities uh and and working to make
sure the products work for them all that
there's a lot of work still left to do
one thing i would say is ai offers new
opportunities to do it in a in a way we
couldn't have solved it before and so
that's what why when you look at things
like translation or transcription or all
that i think offers us to support these
groups better than ever before you guys
have talked so much about ai and it's
weird and kind of also interesting when
i talk to my non-tech friends their kind
of perception of ai like you think of
what you see in these big high budget
movies like robots running around
everywhere and like that's not the
actual reality of it so do you want to
talk a little bit about like what ai
actually is and how you guys kind of
implement it in all of your devices so
coming in many ways the kind of ai we
are talking about is as humans like you
and i are using language fluently we're
looking at each other we have context
all this is very very hard for computers
to do
so we are trying to make progress and
make computers be a bit smarter
and and using ai to make those things
better but it offers promise in a
different way because the same ai can be
an expert on many topics so it could be
like you're talking to a thousand
different experts on any topic right
that's the potential so you can imagine
a kid in the future
being able to learn on any topic
regardless of where they're growing up
what access they have so that's the
potential we see but when we speak about
ai a lot of it is about how do we use
that to bring more knowledge to more
people and so that's how we think about
it i love that too because learning i
learned almost everything that i know
now
from google and watching youtube videos
and i feel like a lot of kids learn in
different ways and a lot of times
classrooms aren't equipped for that so
the fact that you guys are building that
out and also making it accessible is
just i think that's it really is life
changing yeah i mean i i mean i i wish i
had youtube when i was growing up i've
learned on so many topics
by particularly even through the
pandemic just youtube was a place i
would go learn from uh creators like you
and so you know hopefully this is all
part of the journey in uh making it
easier for people by the way ai also one
one feature we launched today was to
automatically create chapters and
youtube videos you know uh yeah the
crowd goes wild i'm going to put in a
sound effect here
that's amazing too because you're trying
to find that information quickly and the
fact that those chapters are automatic i
cannot wait to try it yeah we're still
talking about ai and because google is
such a huge company you guys can
literally do anything so i feel like you
guys have a responsibility to kind of
set those principles and i know you
talked a little bit about that do you
want to expand a little more on that you
know i mean obviously it's a you know
profound technology and both will have
useful things can be misused can have
harmful effects
so at a from a ground up we have to
think about it right and so we we
publicly stated ai principles and it has
seven core areas you see some of that
work today when we talked about monk
scale or what we did in our cameras last
year across a range of skin tones being
able to capture that well on camera is
an example of the kind of responsible ai
work work we are doing so we are
thinking it through across everything we
do i love the demonstration that you
guys did with lambda2 and that kind of
conversational technology is really just
it's so impressive the fact that you
could make those lists like which one
was your favorite oh yeah you know
played around with it so much what's
stunning for me is how it breaks down
every topic and then it makes you think
about things which you wouldn't have
thought of and you know i think i really
tried planning a party and seeing all
the stuff and even for something you
think you know it surprises you there's
a creativity to all this and you know
you can imagine you're anywhere like a
planet made of ice cream and you can
think through that so you can imagine
being an author and you're writing
something and you can play with it to
get inspiration and so that is the power
of what if if he can get all this to
work well that's the power power ahead
another thing is i love your kind of
initial story of kind of you know
working with chrome and that was really
impactful for me because i feel like a
lot of my career has been people telling
me i shouldn't do this or i shouldn't do
that and when you have sort of that
conviction that something is something
and it can be something like that's
really was touching for me so like do
you have any advice for any young
entrepreneurs or creators or developers
who are kind of getting started and how
to kind of combat hurdles that's good
look i think it's important to remember
you're going to have setbacks it doesn't
go exactly the way you some sometimes it
does but that's rare
for most people kind of meanders and
you know it takes longer than you think
it is
i think working with people who you
think are very good i think that's
important
working something which
kind of clicks inside you you feel it if
you work on something you like
you will feel it inside and i think
that's important to try and find it if
you can and so if you do that and you're
doing your best that's what's in your
control and as i said earlier to young
entrepreneurs there's no better time to
be an entrepreneur like i would ignore
what's happening in the short term like
there is so much opportunity ahead over
the next 10 years or 20 years i think to
creators there you know there's no
better time to be a creator and so you
know that's how i would think about it
yeah i guess one last question i guess
the future of tech i mean it's all
moving so quickly so what is your kind
of big picture vision for the next five
to ten years from our standpoint you
know we we are working on you know given
our goal is to help give access to
knowledge
we think computing is going to evolve
dramatically over the next 10 years you
know we will evolve beyond phones and
you saw some hints at the end of what we
think that world will be and so building
that out and putting it in people's
hands and is something we are super
excited by that's so awesome well thank
you so much for chatting and thank you
to my audience for watching i know
they're going to be so excited subscribe
and click on the bell yes like and
comment on the video
this is the best day ever
can we get a selfie of course oh my gosh
this is incredible all right here we go
all right
[Music]
awesome all right thank you thank you so
nice to meet you trying to keep up pace
with your selfie skills
[Music]
so this was both of our first google
items yes which was so much fun and you
were a veteran yes uh it's 17 18 19. oh
wow yeah and he did not tell us that it
was cold it was very cold i'm sorry it's
freezing i had a lot of fun yeah i can't
wait to see your interview i can't wait
yeah because we couldn't hear anyone
yeah yeah so guys make sure you go check
out both of their videos i'll put links
in the description and i think that's a
wrap
i gotta go to the airport now
you're leaving tomorrow yeah i'm good
bye
[Music]